- [Presenter] The US is
watching Moscow closely in 2020.
Two weeks before the election,
the FBI indicted six Russians
on charges of engaging
in cyber attacks on the
2018 Winter Olympics
and the 2017 French election.
- No country has weaponized
its cyber capabilities
as maliciously and
irresponsibly as Russia.
- [Presenter] Meanwhile,
Microsoft reported
that a Russian hacker
group attacked hundreds
of political organizations and campaigns.
And a Facebook investigation
discovered a network
of Russian trolls that paid Americans
to write for a fake news site.
US authorities have been
cracking down to prevent
what happened during the 2016
US presidential election.
- Russia is behind the hacks
that brought Democratic party
and Clinton campaign
emails into the public eye.
The growing fewer over
Moscow's use of social media
to influence the 2016
presidential election.
- [Presenter] The US
accused Russia of hacking
and trolling attempts aimed at hurting
the Democratic candidate in 2016.
Moscow has denied any
interference in the US elections.
- US officials experts
at social media companies
and researchers at
cybersecurity firms all say
that Russia remains a very
active and very serious threats
one that everybody is
very much on the lookout
for even after election day.
Well, officials and
cybersecurity experts say
they haven't found as
much activity from Russia
and as we saw in the 2016,
they say Russian hackers and ensured
they have expanded their toolkit
and have become much more sophisticated
and harder to detect.
- [Presenter} In 2016, Russian
trolls created fake Accounts
and posted memes that
attacked Hillary Clinton.
They also bought
advertisements on Facebook
and organized events including
ones that drew support
for Donald Trump.
This year, the trolls
tried something different.
They set up a network
of accounts and pages
that were largely linked to a
website called Peacedata.net.
But to anyone who knows Russian,
the website's name hinted
at it's trolling origin.
When you say Peace Data quickly,
it sounds like a Russian obscenity.
- Peace Data tried to look
like a credible news outlet
and trick people into then
relying on that as their news.
- [Presenter] After a tip from the FBI,
Facebook said it
discovered that Peace Data
was run by people linked
to a Russian troll factory
called the Internet Research Agency.
It had been accused by US
authorities of designing
a social media campaign
to provoke political
and social discourse.
- What we found was a
website that was entirely run
by fake personas.
- [Presenter] Ben Nimmo runs
investigations at Graphica,
a research firm that
contracts with Facebook
to analyze foreign social
media manipulation.
He says the trolls in 2016
mainly created group accounts
but in 2020, Peace Data's
trolls got more personal.
- They have profile
pictures which are generated
by artificial intelligence.
They then had a number of
accounts across Facebook
and Twitter and LinkedIn.
And what they were doing was
they were hiring real people,
authentic freelancers to
write content for them.
- So this does a few things for them,
it does sort of separate Russia
from the direct influence
operation in a way
that might make it harder
to track, harder to identify
and it also leads to
organic content in some ways
that seems more real, seems more authentic
because it's being written
by a native English speaker
who knows about American politics.
- [Presenter] The Russian
embassy in Washington DC
said Facebook's allegations
are anti-Russia propaganda.
Facebook, Twitter and
LinkedIn tipped down accounts
and pages linked to Peace Data.
The website was eventually closed.
In total, the site actually
had a very small following.
Overall, the traffic seems
to have not read the levels
that we saw in 2016
but that might only be
a small representation
of all the websites out there that Russia
or anyone else is using to try
to influence American voters.
And so if we can understand the tactics,
I think that helps us to be on alert
for similar kind of behavior
that might be on the platforms.
After the exposure of
Peace Data, another website
which was exposed, which is called NAEBC
which posted as a far right
white supremacist site
was behaving in very much the same way.
Hiring unwitting
freelancers to write for it.
- [Presenter] The hacks have also evolved.
In September, Microsoft
said it detected activity
from the same Russian hackers
who were behind the attacks
on the Democratic campaign in 2016.
The software giants at this time,
the hackers had new reconnaissance tools
instead of emailing malicious
links to steal passwords,
they deployed password sprays
which essentially guesses passwords
with multiple automated attempts.
Microsoft said most of the cyber
attacks weren't successful.
The Russian embassy in Washington DC
denied Microsoft allegations.
- The conspiracy of Russian military and--
- [Presenter] Realizing
the threat this year,
multiple US security
agencies are working together
to share intelligence with
social media platforms.
A Senate investigation
found that US tech giants
helped spread misinformation
during the 2016 election
and lawmakers pushed the
companies to better coordinate.
- Heading into 2016
the idea of cooperating
on something like election interference
was just not happening
but this was just essentially
after the Edward Snowden
leaks of surveillance secrets
from the national security agency
which really increased
tensions between Silicon Valley
and the government.
- [Presenter] Despite the team effort,
it's still difficult to
publicize Russian activities
and not create confusion.
- Officials and companies
are constantly grappling
with the challenge of informing the public
about foreign interference
without being overly alarmist
about it and scaring them so much
that it actually accomplishes the goal
of a lot of these foreign
influence operations
which is just to sow chaos and discord
to play on the existing
tensions we have in America.